the crown is back with its fourth season
which continues to highlight the lives
struggles and successes of the british
royal family
like previous seasons it's largely based
on historical events
first is the show's portrayal of the
relationship between prime minister
margaret thatcher
and queen elizabeth ii you see i
consider myself to be exactly like them
i'm trying to move too fast that is
because
i am in a hurry thatcher played by
gillian anderson
served from 1979 to 1990. i didn't have
you down as a sports woman
i'm not mom though she and the queen
played by olivia coleman might not have
outwardly argued
there was a tense curtness to their
relationship on the show
hey what did you do together we
worked historians say their real-life
meetings maintained a rigidness
throughout thatcher's time in office
princess diana first lady diana spencer
is another focal point of season four
emma coren depicts the soon-to-be
princess in one of the most anticipated
story arcs of the series
it's the prince of wales her age is also
accurately depicted
diana was still in her teens when she
met prince charles
eventually marrying him at age 20. he
was 32.
hello the show only briefly depicts
their wedding
day which in real life attracted
millions of viewers around the globe
the crown also delves into the darker
sides of diana and her relationships
a scene in episode 3 shows her indulging
in sweets from the refrigerator
soon later she's vomiting it all back up
lady diana did in fact have bulimia
as the scene suggests
camilla parker bowles is another focal
point of the season
bowles played by emerald vanell was
prince charles's former girlfriend
ahead of his marriage to diana but their
love
and relationship ensued throughout
charles and diana's time together
despite their marriage he hopes he tells
you everything
we talk most days some including diana
would agree that camilla had a role in
the demise and eventual
end of her marriage to prince charles do
you think mrs parker-bowles was a factor
in the breakdown of your marriage well
there were three of us
in this marriage so it was a bit crowded
charles and camilla were married in
[Music]
2005.
you